This episode of DNews is brought to you by
the Toyota Prius.
Let’s lead the way.
So you’re walking down the street with an
empty water bottle in your hand and toss it
in a trashcan thinking “it’s one bottle.
It’s not the end of the world if I don’t
recycle it.”
Well, that one little bottle can make a big
difference.
Hey guys, Amy here with DNews.
Plastics, and specifically plastic bottles,
are one of the fastest-growing elements of
municipal waste in America.
The Environmental Protection Agency (EPA)
estimates that as much as 12 percent of all
U.S. solid waste is plastic products.
That’s a lot, and it’s something we can
actually do something about.
Water bottles are typically made of polyethylene
terephthalate or PET, and it’s delightfully
easy to recycle and reuse.
When a PET bottle is recycled, it’s sent
to a facility where it is ground down into
flakes, cleaned, then melted into small pellets.
Those pellets can then be used to make new
bottles — a far more energy and cost efficient
process than making a new bottle from raw
materials — or recycled into something different.
When a PET bottle isn’t recycled, it goes
to a landfill.
And because it’s not biodegradable it will
sit there forever, taking up space and letting
material that could be reused just sit there.
The average American uses about 167 bottles
of water each year.
With about 316 million people living in this
fair country, that amounts to 52,772,000,000
plastic water bottles every year.
And of those 167 bottles, that average American
only recycles 38 bottles, so that’s about
12,008,000,000 recycled around the country.
That means a little more than 40 billion bottles
end up in landfills, which is equivalent to
more than $1 billion in plastics.
Granted, plastic water bottles are convenient.
It’s great to be able to grab a bottle when
you’re rushing through an airport and dehydrated,
but we need to stop throwing them all away.
About 7.4 cubic yards of landfill space is
saved for every ton of plastic that is recycled.
Which is good, though we’re not exactly
experiencing a landfill shortage.
Though the number of landfills in America
have decreased in the last two decades from
nearly 8,000 sites to a little over 1,600,
the average size has increased meaning they
can store more materials.
But recovery of materials, like plastic bottles
sent for recycling, has also increased in
the same time frame.
And we can keep that trend going.
If every person held on to one bottle a little
longer until they found a recycling bin, we
could save both resources and space.
It’s a really small thing to do, but the
impact is significant.
So, how often do you guys cart old bottles
around until you find a place to recycle them?
Let us know in the comments below or you can
catch me on Twitter as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.